hello internet welcome to film theory a
show that's coming to you live from the
back rooms why because i have no idea
how to get out of here internet speed's
good though and the moist carpet water
is uh
it's not the best i've ever had but you
know it'll do wait what was that noise
for all of you who are uninitiated the
monotone misery that is the back rooms
began back in 2019 when this image was
posted to a 4chan board dedicated to
unsettling images just an ugly series of
rooms right no big deal well it came
packaged with the following text quote
if you're not careful and you no clip
out of reality in the wrong areas you'll
end up in the back rooms where it's
nothing but the stink of old moist
carpet the madness of mono yellow the
endless background noise of fluorescent
lights at maximum hum buzz and
approximately 600 million square miles
of randomly segmented empty rooms to be
trapped in god save you if you hear
something wandering around nearby
because it sure hurt you
this post immediately got under people's
skin that endless series of mild
annoyances that make you feel squeaky
and uncomfortable slightly wet socks a
faint electric buzz harsh lighting ugly
wallpaper in short it is mundane horror
an oppressive monotony that slowly wears
you down mentally and physically that
miserable setting inspired lots of
online artists to write their own
independent creepypastas even creating a
short video game where you explore the
space but here in 2022 the back rooms
have suddenly exploded in popularity
thanks to a new series by vfx artist
kane pixels who has taken the basic
concept and started to build a full-on
world around it and you know what that
means
kane's first backroom short film takes
place in well already we hit a bit of a
snag the slate says july 4th 1990
something but the description of the
video actually has september 23rd 1996.
anyway this is probably just because it
was the first video in the series dates
become much clearer as the world gets
more and more developed
things start off instantly when a
cameraman fittingly enough named kane
tries to set up a wide shot and
immediately falls through the ground
literally no clipping through reality
only to wind up in the dank and deserted
world full of humming florescent lights
retro carpeting yellow walls endless
corridors and monsters that at least at
first glance remind me of walking
tripods our cameraman wanders around
trying to find an escape along the way
he finds some interesting landmarks
hidden amongst the endless walls but
ultimately he's caught and presumably
killed by the weird
fungi monster it's short it's simple
it's effective since the massive success
of that first back rooms video kane has
been busy expanding the world with other
shorts like the third test first contact
and missing persons as well as making
the accompanying collateral.mov and
march 11 1990 archive archive.tar which
are both hidden in the descriptions of
the various videos from all of them we
ultimately learned that the back rooms
was an experiment designed by a company
named async to solve space issues
providing near limitless room for both
storage and housing in an ever-shrinking
world where it all went wrong though
remains to be seen but what i want to
focus on today isn't the where and the
why but rather the how how to survive in
the fourth video the main series we see
that since accessing the back rooms in
1989 missing persons reports have been
skyrocketing as more and more people
fall out of reality never to return so
if that were you what do you do how do
you navigate a seemingly endless maze
with limited resources long enough to
potentially figure out this mysterious
world how do you avoid an unknown
monster that roams the halls what
mistakes do we see kane make in his
exploration of the back rooms and what
could we do better pay attention friends
because today i have the definitive list
of six tactics that might just save your
life the next time you no clip out of
reality into an ugly yellow nightmare in
collateral.mov we learned that in 1989
tests by the async foundation caused a
massive earthquake that took place in
the santa cruz mountains so is the
facility in the mountains are you at the
top of a mountain and need to go down
are you under the mountain and you need
to go up are you in the upside down and
you need to get on upside down in it's
unclear at best all we know is that in
one moment we were filming with friends
and in the next we're here so once you
land in the back rooms the first thing
that you need to do is take the advice
of the us forest service which suggests
that when you get lost in the woods or a
cave you do not move at all unless you
have a specific reason to take a step
basically you sit down you don't panic
you assess the situation and the tools
that you have at your disposal and you
stay where you are you ended up at this
location for a reason maybe this is an
entry point for other people and someone
else will know clip in maybe people will
wind up looking for you and by moving
you throw off their tracking in short by
panicking running and moving forward
without a clear plan of attack you are
only succeeding in getting yourself more
and more lost eventually though you will
need to move and this was kane's first
mistake he had no plan he just wandered
aimlessly and headed towards whatever
looked interesting this meant that when
he started getting chased by the back
rooms as monster he had no idea of his
surroundings and wound up meeting a dead
end figuratively or i guess it would be
literal anyway proper grammar aside
we're in a repetitive maze we're looking
for an exit and we need a way to track
our movements and for that we need to
use a maze solving algorithm an
automated strategic way for solving the
maze with no prior knowledge of it our
first strategy should be using the wall
follower technique also known as the
right hand rule this is one that i think
a lot of people have heard of but maybe
don't understand the actual mechanics of
basically it's a tried and true maze
escaping method that involves running
your right hand along a wall while you
navigate the maze you see mazes in their
simplest terms are just shapes that
you're trapped inside so you as the maze
solver need to find the outermost wall
and the hole that's presumably in it
many mazes are what's known as simply
connected i.e all the walls are
connected together to the maze's outer
boundary as such if you were to unwind
the maze it basically amounts to one big
circle with an entrance hole and an exit
hole so by keeping your hand locked to
one wall and following it all the way
through you follow the outline of that
circular path and you either find the
exit congratulations you survive or you
wind up looping back to where you first
started well that's certainly not ideal
it is helpful because it tells us that
the maze isn't simply constructed but
rather it's what's known as a disjoint
maze one where the walls aren't always
connected to the outer boundary in the
video first contact we actually get
confirmation that this is what we're
dealing with with the back rooms we see
a map that confirms that the back rooms
is a disjoint maze notice that there are
multiple chunks of wall here that don't
seem to connect to the outside line but
just because we're in a more complicated
maze doesn't mean that we're out of
options first and foremost if kane was
able to bring his camera with him into
the back rooms then his other belongings
have no clipped with him as well
specifically things on his body like
keys and clothes and this immediately
puts us at a huge advantage if you have
something like keys or a belt you should
immediately mark your starting location
on the wall and then run those keys or
belts or whatever against the wall to
leave indentations or markings you can
scuff the walls with your shoes you can
peel the wallpaper you can pull a hansel
and gretel and rip pieces of your
clothing off to use as breadcrumbs you
can write arrows and notes to yourself
on the walls which we know can be done
since there are markings throughout the
maze left by other people this way when
our right hand method results in us
doubling back to where we began we have
a clear indication of which walls we
followed and which ones we didn't and if
the walls do happen to be somehow
supernatural and can't be marked by you
then the ceiling tiles are another
option here you see the ceilings of the
back rooms appear to be a specific type
known as a drop ceiling or suspended
ceiling which is common in office
environments where lightweight foam
panels hang a few inches below the main
structural ceiling hiding things like
wires and support beams by throwing a
shoe to break or knock down tiles you're
able to mark your progress in all the
areas that you've been bit by bit you
eliminate the hallways that you've
tracked and systematically work your way
to the outer edges of the maze one other
strategy to help with this in a disjoint
maze setup like the back rooms is the
pledge algorithm here you travel in a
set direction let's say you walk forward
until you hit an obstacle from there you
put your right hand on the wall and you
start walking around the obstacle
counting the angles that you're turning
clockwise turns are positive
counterclockwise turns are negative once
you start facing the original direction
that you're meant to move again and the
sum of your turns is zero you leave the
obstacle and you continue moving in your
original direction this ultimately gets
you off the disjoints faster leading you
to the outer wall of the maze and
eventually to the exit right now all you
seasoned back rumors are probably
laughing at me and saying silly mad pat
the back rooms are an endless void of
death and despair that'll cause you to
slowly lose your mind to which i say
joke's on you i lost my mind years ago
i'm not gonna let a funky smelling
series of yellow rooms defeat me plus
not convinced that this thing is
actually infinite or unpredictable like
i said in this new cane pixel series we
see a map of the place we also see async
employees able to walk through the back
rooms using a long red line presumably
as a way to lead them back to the
entrance store so all of that is just
trying our best to find an exit but
there's still one more important
variable here that we have to consider
the monster that's looking to rip our
body in half to use as human nunchucks
and this is again where a systematic
approach to the maze will be our first
line of defense the last thing that we
want is to wind up in a dead end and the
best thing that we can do to avoid that
is to use the confusing layout to our
advantage ideally we're able to lead
this monster to a disjoint a section of
the maze that we already know loops back
around on itself this gives us two
simultaneous benefits first and most
importantly we don't get lost while
still allowing us to use the narrow
hallways and looping structure to escape
the sight lines of the monster instead
of taking a straight path where the
creature can easily track and follow us
you instead make tight turns in an
effort to make yourself disappear behind
a series of walls as quickly as possible
this sequence of repeated doors that
kane is chased through provides an
excellent example by dodging and weaving
instead of taking a straight path he
should be able to make himself disappear
fairly quickly the other benefit of
using a big disc joint to escape this
thing though is that we can then try to
loop back around behind the monster to
follow it obviously your first priority
is going to be avoiding this thing until
you have a better sense of what it is
and what it can do but by leading it to
a chunk of maze that you know will allow
you to double back around it you'll be
able to sneakily gather information much
more quickly and who knows these things
presumably know the layout of the maze
so by following them they may be able to
provide another resource for finding the
way out i suppose you could try to fight
it or try to trap it with a rope or drag
it into a null zone which you wouldn't
even know about but honestly is
confronting this thing actually gonna
help you survive probably not focus on
escape and defense as your first
priority once all that's settled you've
created a system that actually works
you've learned that the walls don't
magically change every 30 minutes start
grabbing whatever you can find in the
back rooms video kane blatantly ignores
a lot of potentially useful supplies for
instance that ladder right there that's
used to get into the crawlspace grab it
and carry it around even better try to
use it to get into the ceiling grid
remember what i said about suspended
ceilings that it hangs below what the
real top of the room is well often walls
only go as high as the dropped ceiling
height as such once you're in the
ceiling you're not only hidden from the
ground-based monsters but you also have
a wide open path to the outer edge of
the maze unobstructed by any walls heck
you might even be able to find some
electrical wires from the fluorescent
lights that you can then follow which
again should presumably be leading you
out of the facility also if you come
across some rope in a dumpster you don't
walk past it you check out what's inside
the dumpster and you take the rope you
take what the world gives you because
you might not ever come across it again
the same goes for any chair legs that
could be used for self-defense or heck
something inside of the filing cabinets
that you walk past remember you are
stuck in a maze everything can have
multiple uses for instance when kane's
walking up the fire escape his camera
catches a glimpse of a hole in the
ceiling that's created by an air duct
air ducts as you can probably guess tend
to lead to the outside of buildings so
again having that ladder or rope might
have helped him to investigate that when
he comes across a cavernous section of
the back rooms those same items could
have helped him get across the chasm to
the other side if he had a ladder he
could have dropped down into the
apartment area that we see here allowing
him to more efficiently look for food
and water sure nothing might come of any
of these options but again it's more
likely to work than just wandering
around aimlessly surrounded by
repetitive yellow wallpaper last but
certainly not least don't take any
one-way exits unless you absolutely have
to while running away from the monster
kane ends up sprinting deep into the
catacombs only to find a hole that he
jumps down into it was the right
decision in the moment because he was
being chased but had he just found the
hole this would have left him vulnerable
because it's a decision that he can't
easily reverse again document on the
walls with your keys or whatever that
the hole is this way but only come back
to it if nothing else seems to be
working again the last thing you want to
do is to corner yourself so there you
have it friends how to survive the back
rooms in six easy steps one have a
maze-solving strategy two mark your path
using whatever's on you three equip
yourself with anything and everything
that you can find four ceilings wires
and air ducts are gonna be your friend
five never take a one-way path always
have at least two ways out and six if
you absolutely have to use the
disjointed confusing layout defensively
when being attacked using all those
tactics you have the best chance
possible of escaping this nightmare
scenario and hey look on the bright side
if you ever get thirsty you have as much
moist carpet water to drink as you could
possibly want but hey it's february and
if there's anything scarier than the
back rooms it's valentine's day but fear
not my friends because i've got the
definitive strategy for surviving
valentine's day in one easy step getting
a gift from our sponsor for today's
episode established titles done and done
theorists see here's the thing
established titles is just a fun gift to
give someone who's nerdy and loves a
little bit of fantasy in their lives
through established titles you can buy a
small piece of land in scotland which
thanks to an old scottish custom means
that you or the person you're buying the
land for officially becomes what's known
as a laird that's a lord or lady for us
modern english speakers plus with every
order established titles plants a tree
partnering with global charities to help
preserve the scottish woodlands
stephanie is a huge fan of all things uk
so this just felt like the perfect gift
for her and you can get as goofy and
over the top with the title that you
choose as you want so from henceforth
stephanie shall now be known as lady
stephanie drinker of tea lover of naps
she of the icy hands plus you can even
do couples or family title packs so you
know that i had to get me in on some of
this action you may now only address me
as lord matpat slayer of lore ruiner of
childhoods he of the red jacket and hair
swoop needless to say this present was
an epic win and if you or someone in
your life would like to officially
become a named lord or lady now's the
time to get your title established
titles is already doing a massive
valentine's day sale but because you
guys are fans of the channel you can
actually get an additional 10 off any
purchase that you make using the
discount code film theorist that's
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-i-s-t
so head on over using the link down in
the description below to get your land
and official certificate of lord or
ladyship the thing even comes framed
which is just a really nice touch you
just throw it up on the wall to brag to
all your friends the next time they come
over oh yeah where's your scottish plot
of land so if you're looking for an
excuse to get a little fancy this
february head on down to the description
and click the link or head over to
establishtitles.com
film theorists and use the promo code
film theories to get your additional 10
off at checkout that's
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-i-s-t
and as always remember me lords and
ladies it's all just a theory a film
theory this is lord matpat's slayer of
lore saying see you next week